okay question from
nota gang members and profit j-cal do
you have an independent investment
advisor great question
no before the stock market crashed in
2008
i said you know i'm getting nervous
about the stock market i want you to
tell me what are the safest things that
grow four or five percent he's like well
bonds i guess is what most people would
answer i said okay uh do bonds ever go
down i'm like oh yeah of course so the
gizmo scenarios and i said okay well
what's the safest bond or the most
reliable bonds and he said municipal
bonds that are uh revenue-backed bonds i
said what is that so you know when they
build a bridge
i said yeah i know about building
bridges you know they do a bond i'm like
yeah i'm not an idiot they build the
bottom of the bridge he goes well
revenue back means that legally anytime
the toll money comes in that has to pay
back the bondholders first and then
they're saying okay now you're telling
me something i don't know you're saying
legally they can't default on that bond
as long as people are paying 17 to go
across the verrazano i'm a dip [ __ ] kid
from bay ridge i know that bridge i know
everybody talks about that how expensive
it is so i want the bond for the
verrazano bridge he said well that
there's no bond for that but whatever
anyway he says municipal bonds he said
okay i said i take all my money and buy
me only municipal months because that's
gonna take a long time and i said not
for me
it's gonna take you a long time
and
he then proceeded to buy me municipal
bonds because you they they were not
they're not traded like
normally on like an exchange somewhere
so i moved everything into municipal
bonds that were revenue backed and when
i did that uh the stock market crashed
18 months later so i missed that last
little uptick but uh the bonds became
worth more because everybody flooded to
them so the basis of those revenue back
bonds that somehow went up and they were
paying four or five percent so they
became this like
during the market crash of 2008 i was
going up
they called me jake how you're a genius
how do you know about papa and i was
like well i just was scared that's wha i
knew i was scared i was scared about
watching everybody i was buying a home
at the time and i was like
they were telling me while i was buying
a home to lie on my
um
income thing and to do a no reference
check or no revenue check mortgage i was
like what's that it's like well it's a
mortgage where you we don't check your
income and i was like
well you have to check the income he's
like yeah it's a new kind of mortgage i
was like
a non
yeah i forgot what they called it but it
was like a no
auditing of your financials
uh mortgage product and it cost a little
more and you could just buy more like
you should buy five million dollar house
you buy 10 million
and i was like but i can't afford that
and they were like yeah but you know
with this you know you just flip it five
years from now it's like well what if i
can't flip it he's like oh yeah but you
can flip it i mean look historically and
i was like
yeah that sounds really dumb to me so
anyway
at that point i said listen nothing
personal but i had to every time i
wanted to transfer money or every time i
wanted to
do anything with my own money um i
couldn't text my money manager to do it
he'd make me call him and he was a nice
guy
but then he want to talk about the
knicks he wanted to ask me about my
family it was like a whole moment for
him to
bond with me and that's very nice but i
don't want to talk to you i just want to
send 50 000 to the cage at the aria and
he would ask me oh what's this for and
i'm like for me to go be a complete
degenerate in vegas
i'm sending you 50 i'm sending 50 000 to
the cage in the aria what do you think
it's for it's not for dinner
it's too gay i would love to read that
profile on cnbc imagine that they did a
profile on you how you made it through
the recession you're like what was your
strategy it was amazing you're like i
was just along the verrazano bridge
basically it's a long bridge i always
log the bridge i don't know i was along
the bridge that's it the bridge it's the
longest bridge they have that island
underrated underrated burrow i was like
that that was the worst burrow and that
they would be less than the worst at
some point because queens sucks no
offense is queens i'm joking um i mean
queens is the second taurus borough uh
brooklyn manhattan bronx queens staten
island
don't mention anyway that's it so i
fired my money manager essentially i
didn't fire them i don't make it
dramatic but i just said i'm gonna
manage my own money and then i looked at
it i read all the books on managing your
money and it was basically like be
diversified
and then i had wealth front and i was
like okay well that's diversified by
default and i was like i have access to
the one investment class everybody wants
which is early stage startups
i have a massive advantage i'm the
number one angel in the world right now
the other ones retired i would have been
number five if soccer and montgomery and
everybody else didn't retire from angel
investing so
why would if if you were the number one
at something why would you go
try to be number 2 000 at something
that's when people like why don't you
trade crypto or why don't you trade nft
so why don't you trade this and why
don't you do spax i'm like because i'm
good at this
like when michael jordan went to play
baseball people were like well that's a
waste of two seasons we could have
watched him play basketball
i'm really good at what i do so why
would i do that and then people email
like hey hey i want to introduce myself
or morgan stanley oh hey i wanna
introduce myself come zach we'd love to
talk to you about your money management
your strategy i'm like my strategy is to
put
everything into safe balanced portfolio
with the lowest fees possible and then
take
massive risk investing in startups what
do you think of that strategy like oh my
god it's a probably strategy marvel
strategy but i'm like great how would
you change it
crickets
friggins well let's get on the phone or
maybe we should go to you know per se
i'm gonna go to mission start restaurant
i'm like listen guys
i just sent them a link to the book i'm
like can you beat these returns if you
have a strategy to beat these returns
and i send them the cover of the book
then call me back until then i'm gonna
manage my own money and they're like we
can't beat your returns i'm like so why
would i use you why would i pay you one
percent of my money like one percent of
my money is a bigger number now like i
could hire a staff for that amount which
i do i have a staff
so anyway i think uh money managers are
super overrated uh i you know i i
think using wealthfront and managing
your own money is a better strategy i
think the best strategy is to be is the
barbell strategy safety over here
and then really high risk stuff over
here that could change your life
and that's i think a really
that's my personal belief you take it
for what it's worth i don't know what
you paid for this advice but that's the
advice